[Applaudissements]
des manifestations contre parcours sub
la plate forme d'inscription dans le
supérieur lancé en 2018 du jamais les
avants est-ce qu'il était plus facile de
s'inscrire à l'université
retour dans les années 80 à l'époque
mieux valait avoir beaucoup de temps à
quelle heure ils vont arriver et un peu
de chance alors souvent les choix
n'étaient pas dictées par la volonté des
candidats les dogues de droit et de
langues et trucs comme ça y est déjà des
coûts de 400 personnes alors on n'a pas
su réunir s'inscrit aussi en médecine un
peu plus de justice dans les années 90
grâce au minitel 36 15 ravel pour
l'ile-de-france 36 15
racine pour toulouse et 36 15 brotas sup
pour la bretagne
le candidat pouvait formuler trois voeux
sauf que parfois il se retrouvait sans
fil hier à la rentrée pas contents les
futurs noms d'étudiants et bien tant pis
pour eux
ravel propose les présidents
d'université dispose ce sont elles qui
affecte et qui inscrivent dans le cadre
de l'autonomie des universités 2009
est-ce qu'internet fera mieux que le
minitel c'est l'ambition de la nouvelle
plate forme d'inscription baptisé
admission post bac apb pour les intimes
je mets sur recherche licence plage et
tout ce que je peux tout savoir inscrire
24 veut possible au total contre trois
sur ravel
mais là encore les candidats ne sont pas
rassurés franchement pas évident de
pouvoir se retrouver dans toutes ces
fiers surtout que à notre âge on sait
pas vraiment ce qu'on veut à la rentrée
2010 est la dernière d'apb trois mille
bacheliers étaient restés sans
affectation l'année suivante
passage de relais à parcours sup un
étudiant sur quatre disent et à leur
avoir validé son voeu d'orientation par
des piques
[Musique]